I want to start today by talking
generally about political violence in
the United States what I mean by this is
acts of real world violence that are
politically motivated or politically
oriented and of course the context is
this horrifying attack by a right-wing
anti-vaccine
anti-semitic Q Anon nut on Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi which we
will get to but one of the things that
the right has been doing in response to
this horrible attack to this obviously
politically motivated attack is a lot of
both sidesing well we generically
condemn violence and violence is bad no
matter who does it violence in general
is unacceptable but let's not pretend
that it is the same on both sides first
of all they aren't actually telling the
truth that they see left and right-wing
violence in the same way their reaction
to the January January 6 Trump riots
excuse me is great evidence of that but
more importantly they they are looking
to say well just violence is bad but
overwhelmingly the violence comes from
their side there's a very good study
from the new America Think Tank which
found that most political violence is
right wing and in fact they have number
of people killed in deadly attacks in
the post-9 11 ERA this is for deaths and
then we have other incidents of violence
where nobody dies number of people
killed by ideology and you will see that
there's 122 which are far right wing and
107 that are jihadist 17 are ideological
misogynist slash incels
which is another right-wing reactionary
ideology then you've got your black
separatist Nationalist supremacists and
one that is far left wing
other than the one far left wing these
are all essentially right-wing
ideologies now you might say but David
the jihadists folks jihadists are right
wing tell me what left-wing views
jihadist Muslims have they have the
exact same views as the far-right
Christians except under the guise of
Islam rather than Christianity
so overwhelmingly right wing violence is
the cause of of a death in the United
States in politically violent acts
there's another study uh called a
comparison of political violence by
left-wing right wing and Islamic
islamist extremists in the United States
and the world and what this study finds
and we'll link to it and you can read
through it is that most political
violence both domestically in the United
States and globally is carried out by
right-wing ideology by right-wingers now
there is another layer
it isn't just the right wing that is
perpetrating most of the political
violence it's also that the left wing is
mostly the victim of that violence as
well you can have right Wingers
generically committing acts of violence
and the victims are A random assortment
of those based on political ideology but
no it is left Wingers that are
overwhelmingly the victims of this
right-wing violence as well and if you
think we can count on the right to help
reduce such violence forget it think
back to the start of the pandemic they
couldn't even pitch in and just wear
masks or get themselves vaccinated for
the greater good there is no way that
they would pitch in to work together to
make sure Society doesn't collapse uh uh
uh if under the weight of this violence
given that they are overwhelmingly the
ones perpetrating that violence they
hate higher education they say that's
liberal indoctrination uh they um say
that medicine is increasingly uh biased
left-wingers giving their social
opinions when it comes to vaccines and
all these other guidelines related to
the pandemic on all of these different
things they are willing to let the world
the country burn for their ideology it
doesn't matter science doesn't matter
empiricism doesn't matter reality
doesn't matter to them uh the other
aspect to this that is important to
consider
is that when you look at stochastic
terrorism meaning the vague calls to
violence
issued to their respective audiences you
just don't see that on the left now I
know you can find isolated examples of
some black lives matter or antifa
activist with no following other than
1500 people on Twitter saying down with
their heads or something like that but
what I'm talking about is
Tucker Carlson Alex Jones Steve Bannon
Trump himself at rallies the leaders of
their movement prominent people
saying we gotta knock him around knock
the hell out of them I'll pay for the
legal fees all of these different things
they are causing this to a great degree
and so the both sidesism has to stop and
by the way the more we learn about the
Paul Pelosi attack the more we know that
it was simply a right-wing nut targeting
Nancy Pelosi because he doesn't like her
political views let's talk about that
next